we've all got a card or a handful of
cards that make us happy and somehow
manage to Wrangle their way into far
more decks than one would expect just
because we want to play with them more
and this is a very normal human impulse
an Impulse that I share skull storm Shi
mask of memory and the Mages are all
cards that I have lurking in the back of
my mind begging me to put them into a
deck but should that voice be listened
to should these Pet cards be slammed in
as many decks as possible the answer to
that is not a clean yes or no and it
depends on a couple factors first of all
I should Define here what I mean by pet
card this is generally thought of as
cards that players have some sort of
fondness toward but Pet cards can be Pet
cards for a variety of different reasons
players might enjoy the art or flavor
they might find the card's effect cool
and unique and they also might just
really enjoy what the card has to offer
for their deck for starters I want to
address the Pet cards that are either
generally bad or so hyp specific that
it's difficult to find a deck where they
truly feel at home one good option for
these is to build a deck with the
understanding that it's here to fulfill
the most Primal of pet card desires if
it's a card you like for Aesthetics
build a deck that fits that aesthetic if
it's a card you like for its effect find
cards to go with it in some way and make
that the broader thing the deck likely
won't be great but that's fine because
it's not here to be great I doubt any of
this is controversial but I figure I
should express it anyway since this
category of cards often does make up a
non-zero portion of the cards that
people consider their pet cards on the
opposite end of the spectrum there are
the Pet cards that are just good or at
least they're flexible enough never to
feel bad I booked around a bit in forums
and saw a handful of answers like Dawn
charm swans song and Campbell console of
allocation and yeah these cards are just
good and you can put them in a deck of
their colors and they will be almost
guaranteed to feel at decent in a casual
EDH game I mentioned shigeki earlier and
I'd like to put that card in this
category as well I run it in two
different ramp heavy green decks and
having a flexible recursion ability
that's uncounterable and at instant
speed is good enough that the card never
feels dead is that just cope on my part
that's up to you to decide with that
we've knocked out the cases of cards
that aren't very good and cards that are
strong Andor flexible enough to feel
good in most games that leaves us with
the stuff in the middle what does one do
with a moderately potent card with a
somewhat specific use case well there
are two options for this option A is you
take one or two Pet cards and build a
specific deck for them too often I've
seen people keep cards in their deck
that are ill-fitting just because they
like them and while I'm not trying to
shame anybody for playing what they like
I think it's useful to keep in mind that
you're not just doing your deck a
disservice you're also doing that pet
card a disservice you can throw these
sorts of Cards into any old deck whose
color identity they fit but this doesn't
necessarily mean they'll feel satisfying
these sorts of cards won't reach their
full potential if you're playing them in
a deck they only tangentially connect to
and at the worst you might gradually
grow resentment for them if you keep
drawing them rather than a card that is
more useful meanwhile the act of
building a deck that a pet card fully
belongs in is the greatest act of love
you can show your favorite piece of
cardboard and it can also be quite fun
to build around a card that you love
I've done this for astral slide mz's end
and time saeve and in all three cases it
led to a deck that is a blast to play in
which I actively enjoy the process of
tuning some decks built this way will be
stronger than others due to the
potential power of the card in question
the time saeve deck is definitely the
strongest of those last three but the
principle still stands figuring out how
to best Express a card either in terms
of power level or in terms of vibe is a
lot of fun the other option for
utilizing Niche moderately powerful Pet
cards is to put a bunch in one deck
basically to figure out a deck that is
well equipped to handle a number of
different types of effect the astral
slide and mzes and decks I built along
with my Maria Voltron deck are all too
focused to throw other random pet Cards
into without incurring significant
losses to deck quality but there are
other types of deck that are much more
flexible in what sorts of card they can
accommodate one of these is midrange
decks with simple goals and a solid core
my rata deck is running all sorts of Fun
Cards I enjoy and it's able to do this
because the types of card the deck is
looking for are six to seven drops with
some sort of meaningful game impact and
for cost cards that vaguely gesture at
the concept of ramp the deck is also
built on a budget and limited to being
midow by its nature so it can
accommodate a lot of cards that are too
weak for a higher power deck my friend
Hans has a Jensen carth Alan deck that's
basically just five color Beatdown and
the cards that make the cut for what the
deck is looking for is basically
anything that lets it hit people with
Angel tokens more vigorously if you want
a py rule of thumb the more generic a
deck's General game plan is the more
Niche and varied the specific card
choices can be in addition to generic
mid-range decks there are also specific
themes that lend themselves to running
more Niche cards one of these is
proliferate a mechanic I built at a low
power level with a commander that I love
dearly skeleton ship it contains a lot
of Juicy cards I like such as
overwhelming intellect mind Unbound a
couple par enchantments Grim wire of the
dead and several questionable storage
lands among others none of these cards
are irredeemably bad but they're weird
and Niche enough that I was struggling
to find a home for them elsewhere with
the generic template of a pre-con power
proliferate control deck though I can
pack a ton of these cards and have them
all feel appropriate and all get their
chance to shine this can also be scaled
up in power level for a stronger
proliferate deck you could run at trxa
and with that there are all sorts of
options plains walkers are one of the
more popular ones but a friend of mine
built a traxa as a ramp Deck with a
bunch of mogans which ended up pretty
entertaining some other themes that are
pretty flexible and often overlapping
are tokens graveyard stuff and synergies
with a specific card type such as
artifacts or enchantments the key here
is that you need to figure out a solid
core to the deck you should make sure it
has a way to get off the ground usually
by having enough lands ramp and draw and
then you can start to sprinkle in your
spicier stuff and add support Weare
needed for different types of cards it's
also good to make sure you don't forget
to run interaction protection for
vulnerable elements of the deck and
removal to make sure that opponents
don't run away with the game are
important aspects in most decks and
they're too often forgotten in pursuit
of a fun Vision it may be tempting to
disregard these but if you're making a
funny deck how well-rounded it is May
determine whether it ends up being a
deck you want to keep playing with or
whether it ends up getting set aside as
that gimmick deck that was fun for a
little while
to reiterate a couple key points Pet
cards are a fundamental part of the
social Fabric in just about any
collectible card game that exists and
it's obviously silly to suggest that
adding them to decks is flatly wrong at
the same time exercising a bit of
discretion in where these cards are
played can lead to them being more
enjoyable for those decent but somewhat
Niche Pet cards out there there are two
options for fading them into decks
building a deck around a single card or
building a deck that's General enough to
fit a number of these specific cards in
them
a deck that's already focused and
gunning to complete a specific task
probably isn't a great spot for Pet
cards that are only tangentially related
to what the deck is doing but a more
General deck can be a great place to add
in some funkier choices as a final note
the fact that some cards don't go well
in some decks is also why I'm such a big
proponent of budget deck building I
could throw $500 at a fancy deck but for
that same amount I could build a half
dozen Decks at lower budget points that
can also the interests of different
gameplay Styles and different cards I
love when I'm building decks on a higher
budget I need to think harder about how
well a deck will work and how much I'll
actually enjoy it in the long term but
if I'm throwing together a $50 list
based on a card I really like or a funny
premise I can just order that sucker
with no second thoughts knowing that if
I get half a dozen fun games out of it
I'll be happy and to me that's pretty
cool thanks for watching if you got some
Pet cards you really like you can let me
know in the comments both because I like
hearing about Fun Cards people like and
also because it serves my algorithmic
overlords that's a win-win if I ever
heard one